[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a verdict is in in the fake murder uber
trial the case that made the nation
rethink
rideshare safety did nathaniel roland
kidnap and murder college student
samantha josephson
the simple answer typically
not the right answer the tearful
testimony from four
officers describing how they bravely
fought to defend the capitol building on
january 6th
thinking to myself this is how i'm going
to die
defending this entrance and britney
spears asking a judge to remove her dad
as conservator
who she wants to replace him ahead we
look forward to litigating the matter in
court
pam hope appears in court for the first
time for charges in the murder of her
friend
betsy parrier the georgia spa shooter
pleads guilty to four murders
but still could face the death penalty
for more killings law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
after one hour of deliberations a south
carolina jury reached a verdict for the
man accused of murdering a college
student who got into his car
thinking he was her uber ride here's
their verdict
state of south carolina first versus
nathaniel david rowland
for possession of a weapon during the
commission of a violent crime
we visit the jury find the defendant
nathaniel roland is on trial for
kidnapping and murdering 21 year old
samantha josephson
josephson was last seen on surveillance
video around 2 a.m
in march 2019 leaving a bar and getting
into a black vehicle
that reportedly belongs to roland
josephson was stabbed more than 120
times
many defensive wounds prosecutors say
she left a trail of evidence
leading right to the defendant samantha
josephson's footprints
were on the window nathaniel rowlands
impala the inside this
was her cry for help the defense has
tried to draw your attention
to everything except
the evidence that points to mr roland
uh he didn't have any any scratches or
marks on him
well he did they were on the jacket
the striations none of his dna was found
on her body he's wearing long sleeves
he's wearing gloves that decreases the
likelihood of shedding
or sweating or the passing of dna cells
he took her life
and he took the time to try to erase
all the evidence samantha josephson
deserved the chance
to live her life in this man
the defendant nathaniel roland
he took that chance from her
it was malicious it was intentional
and it was cold-blooded but the defense
says
they've got the wrong guy telling the
jury the evidence and lack of his dna
under her fingernails points somewhere
else
nobody has stood up here and said that
nathaniel rowland
was not the one driving the car
but her blood being in the car
and nathanael roland driving the car
does not
mean that he is the one that killed him
guilt i'm sorry killed her there are
32 different times
that nathaniel roland is excluded
from profiles or
is a combination either excluded or
involves other people
32 different times
she put up a fight and the finger roll
and had not a mark on him
that is what we know and mr goldberg
said that she left a trail with her
footprint
well she gave you all the conclusion
with her nails
she told y'all who it was
after their guilty verdict court moved
right into sentencing
the victim's mother pleaded with the
judge to sentence roland to the maximum
possible sentence
her dreams were my dream and her death
was my death
i closed my eyes and i feel what she
endured in his hands
120 times over
and over and over fighting for her life
locked in his
car i used to have dreams for her now
will i have her nightmares
i just wish the state would have
would have done more in finding out
who the actual person was
instead of being satisfied with
with detaining me and improving
my guilt the terror imposed on that
their child and the pain and grief that
you have caused
she was an amazing person an amazing
human being and she obviously put up
an amazing fight against you
and left a sufficient trail for the jury
to see
the sentence of the court for murder is
that you'd be committed to the state
department of
corrections for life defense attorney
bernardo violona
and terry austin bernarda a verdict in
just over an hour with no notes
what do you think was going on in the in
the deliberation room to give us such a
quick verdict
so the jury definitely got the right
verdict they got the right burden
because the prosecution proved beyond a
reasonable doubt that nathaniel rowland
killed uh miss josephson not only did he
kill her but that he
savagely stabbed her over 120 times the
evidence here was so
enormous that the jury didn't have any
doubt as to his guilt and that's why
they came back with a quick verdict
and to be honest i think that what took
them an hour was just them trying to
finish up the lunch because it was
definitely proven beyond a reasonable
doubt
in addition to that the defense's
opening statement
backfired on them when the prosecutor
said the number zero
is the zero amount of people that had
something to do
with her death and that the number 12 is
12 reasons how they've proven that case
beyond
a reasonable doubt yeah the prosecution
definitely flipped out on them in the
closing statements with a more powerful
argument
terry the judge sentenced rowland
immediately and with some strong words
what did you think of the judge's
sentence and what he said to roland
well i think judge newman is everyone's
new hero
he even said that there was an avalanche
of evidence
against roland he said that every single
trail
led right back to this defendant it only
took the jury one hour and seven minutes
because
they had some strong arguments and the
judge actually
talked about some of that that all of
the clothing led back to the defendant
some of the things the prosecution also
said is that this
weapon it was two-sided and it was
one-sided so definitely
more evidence than was needed absolutely
he will be serving
a very lengthy sentence at only 27 years
old
thank you for the input on this the fake
uber murder trial
still ahead on law and crime daily the
shocking plea deal for the atlanta spa
shooter
why this isn't case closed yet but first
britney spears new request in her
conservatorship saga who the pop star
wants on and off her case
our legal analysis after the break
[Music]
welcome back britney spears makes it
official she's asking a judge to remove
her father as conservator of her estate
and replace him with someone else law
and crimes angela levy has the latest on
spears battle
to end the conservatorship brian britney
spears
new attorney filed a 127-page document
asking the court to replace her father
jamie spears with a forensic accountant
for now
britney spears taking steps to end the
conservatorship she's lived under for 13
years her fans
appearing at the most recent hearing
they're moving in the right direction
now that she has her
lawyer that she got to choose but
honestly like she should have never been
sent back
into that situation after everything she
claimed in june
23rd in a new filing spears's new lawyer
matthew rosengart called the
conservatorship a quote kafkaesque
nightmare
i want to thank her fans who have been
incredibly supportive of her
rosengart has asked that jamie spears be
replaced as conservator of the estate
with jason rubin a forensic accountant
rosengart wrote in the filing that jamie
spears has quote profited handsomely
from his daughter's conservatorship
making sixteen thousand dollars per
month on top of other fees from tours
he also writes serious questions abound
concerning mr spears potential
misconduct
including conflicts of interest
conservatorship abuse
and the evident dissipation of ms spears
fortune
estimated to be worth 60 million dollars
which rosengart says
is less than her contemporaries less
than two weeks ago we pledged
that after 13 years of the status quo
my firm and i would move aggressively
and expeditiously to file a petition to
suspend
and remove james p spears jamie spears
has objected to being removed in the
past
meanwhile britney spears's fans will be
watching for his next move
i'm very excited that britney spears has
her own lawyer to fight this
i'm excited to get jamie spears off of
the conservatorship
in the past through his lawyer jamie
spears has said in court that he was
sorry to see his daughter in so much
pain and he has actually
cast a lot of the blame for her
unhappiness on jody montgomery who is
the conservator
of her personal affairs but britney
spears wants montgomery to remain
in that role the next hearing for this
is scheduled for september
brian thanks anjanet back with us is
criminal defense attorney bernardo
villalona and terry austin
terry it's official the request to
remove jamie spears has been submitted
what is the next step for this
conservatorship
well i think this was an important step
to get jamie spears removed and to put
jason rubin on the case he is a
professional fiduciary and he should be
able
to get matters in order and i think the
fact that
in the petition we had the mother
actually saying
that all of what's going on with the
father
is causing britney to not be well and
so i think the next step is going to be
making sure she is well and she's
reserved her right
ultimately to come out of the
conservatorship altogether and that may
be the next step
bernardo this isn't the end of the
conservatorship they are
simply looking to remove jamie spears is
this an indication that brittany
believes
she still needs to be in the
conservatorship no not at all brian this
is just the first step for britney
spears as you can see her attorneys were
much more concerned with
the health the mental health and
emotional state of british fears
with having to deal with her father as
being part of this conservative ship
so they were just focusing on this as
the first step
is to get rid of jamie and they also did
in their motion
is that they reserved their right to
argue to end a conservative ship so we
will be hearing more about this
in the next couple of weeks or so so
definitely the first step of many let's
talk dollars and cents anjanette
was jamie spears making more each month
than his daughter
yeah it appears that way from what
matthew rosengart said in that filing he
said that jamie spears as i mentioned in
the piece was paying himself
to sixteen thousand dollars a month
rosengart says that's actually
two thousand dollars uh more per month
than he was
giving his daughter basically as an
allowance i guess she was getting around
14
000 and he was getting an additional 2
000 for office space
so she's making all this money and has
all this money in the bank but is being
given very little to spend
yeah seems definitely like an allowance
you would give a small child and not
a pop icon such as britney spears who's
pulling in all this money
uh we'll continue to give you an update
on the britney spears conservatorship as
it develops
coming up on law and crime daily robert
durst's defense signals he might not
take the stand in his murder trial for
the killing of his best friend
plus pam hop officially pleads not
guilty to murdering her best friend
betty farrier the case that's capturing
the eyes of true crime junkies inside
the courtroom
next
[Music]
welcome back let's check in on some top
legal stories including the atlanta spa
shooter
pleading guilty to four murders in a
deal that could spare him the death
penalty
at least in one case
robert long admitted to killing four of
the eight people he's accused of
shooting
during a day-long spree of violence in
three massage parlors in georgia
long plead guilty in cherokee county
where the shootings began
but long still faces 19 charges in
fulton county
including murder and domestic terrorism
the fulton county district attorney says
she intends to seek the death penalty
and a hate crime sentencing enhancement
six of the victims were women of asian
descent
a missouri woman accused of killing her
best friend and framing the woman's
husband
made her first appearance in court
tuesday for the case pam hup was charged
earlier this month in the 2011 murder
of betsy farie faria was stabbed 55
times inside her home
in that complaint the state alleges in
that honor about december 27
2011 in the county of lincoln state of
missouri
that after deliberation unknowingly
caused the death of
elizabeth faria by stabbing her husband
russell ferrier
was tried and convicted of her murder
but was acquitted in a 2015 retrial
prosecutors now say hup attacked forrey
to stage the murder as a rage killing by
her husband
hop is currently serving a life sentence
for another murder prosecutors say they
will seek the death penalty
defense attorneys for real estate air
robert durst are asking for a mistrial
again in newly filed court documents
attorneys say mr durst is in an
impossible situation
in that he cannot physically testify in
his own defense at trial
and if he attempted to he raised further
damage to his health or death
durst is on trial for the december 2000
murder of his best friend susan berman
prosecutors are expected to rest their
case this week and the defense will
begin
after durst has signaled multiple times
in court that he plans to take the stand
be sure to tune in to the law and crime
network for capital gavel coverage
now to massachusetts where police
officers sniffed out two suspects
wanted for stealing a puppy in broad
daylight a family known as
eight-month-old black lab
ember was missing from their front yard
wesley police talked to neighbors who
saw in their doorbell camps
a vehicle circling the area the officers
tracked down manual sierra and an
unidentified woman
the officers say they saw ember in their
yard the suspects allegedly say they
took the dog
because one of them is sick police share
the emotional reunion of ember with
their forever family
[Music]
amber is back home and is reportedly
doing very well getting lots of love
both suspects are facing charges of
receiving stolen property
over twelve hundred dollars and
conspiracy
horror to see that four-legged friend
back with his family
when we come back officers give a
first-hand account of the brutal scene
at the capitol on january 6.
their story of how they were protecting
democracy and their message to the
country
next
[Music]
beaten kicked blinded with chemical
irritants
just some of the conditions four
officers testified to enduring
during the capital insurrection they
spoke kindly in front of a house select
committee
investigating the riots the writers call
me traitor
a disgrace and shouted that i
i an army veteran and a police officer
should be executed i too was being
crushed by their riders
i could feel my myself losing oxygen and
recall
thinking to myself this is how i'm going
to die
defending this entrance
at some point during the fighting i was
dragged from the line of officers
and into the crowd i heard someone
scream
i got one as i was swarmed by a violent
mob
they ripped off my badge they grabbed
and stripped me of my radio
they seized ammunition that was secure
to my body
they began to beat me with their fists
and with what felt like hard metal
objects
at one point i came face to face with an
attacker
who repeatedly lunged for me and
attempted to remove my firearm
i heard chanting from some in the crowd
get his gun and kill him with his own
gun
directly in front of me a man sees the
opportunity of my vulnerability
grabbed the front of my gas mask and
used to beat my head against the door
he switched to pulling it off my head
the strap stretching against my skull
and straining my neck
he never uttered any words i recognized
but opted instead for guttural screams
i remember him foaming at the mouth he
also put his cell phone in his mouth so
he had both hands free to assault me
eventually he succeeded in stripping
away my gas mask and a new rush of
exposure to cs and oc spray hid me
the mob of terrorists for coordinating
their efforts now shouting heave
ho as they synchronize pushing their
weight forward pressing you further
against the middle door frame
the man in front of me grabbed my baton
that i still held in my hands
and in my current state i was unable to
retain my weapon he bashed me in the
head and faced with it rupturing my lip
and adding additional injury to my skull
us four officers we would do january 6
all over again we wouldn't stay home
because we knew it was going to happen
we would show up that's courageous
that's heroic so what i asked from you
all is to get to the bottom
of what happened and that includes like
i echoed the sentiments of all the other
officers sitting here
i use an analogy to describe
what i want as a hit man if a hit man
is hired and he kills somebody the
hitman goes to jail
but not only does the hitman go to jail
but the person who hired them does
there was an attack carried out on
january 6.
and a hitman sent them
it's one thing to see the video it's
another thing to hear their words and
their cries out for justice
bernardo what facts are you hearing for
the first time and do they spell out
criminal charges in any way
brian what affected me is what these
officers actually felt what they were
going through because
we saw it on tv we saw it on basically
every news
channel we saw videos but we couldn't
fathom the amount of trauma
that these officers went through what
was said to them what they were feeling
how they were facing
death at this point brian i don't know
if there's going to be additional
criminal charges does it spell out
criminal charges
absolutely but whether the government's
going to be able
to charge the so many people that were
involved
i'm not sure it's going to take some
time and of course the officers being
the victims our hope is that they get
some sort of assistance for that
traumatic experience and when they're
going through terry who is this
committee for at the end of the day
uh what do you think will come of this
hearing
well you know the select committee is
part of the house investigation
of this january 6 event and it is
supposed to be
a you know bipartisan group of
individuals there are actually
seven democrats and two republicans and
nancy pelosi put the group together
and their whole purpose is really to
follow the facts
they're trying to make sure that
something like this happens
again they actually have some power
brian to
issue subpoenas and call witnesses as
you just heard from these police
officers
talking about what they experienced
today so it's unclear
what the end result will be but
certainly we'll have more information
all right all we can do is wait and
follow the facts thank you both and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you